this is 55 Pages there's a lot to get
through we're going to be going through
every line in the morning things that
are just jumping out to start with
though as you're saying there's sort of
very uh personal aspect of it Harry
talking about as a teenager in my early
20s I ended up feeling as though I was
playing up a lot of the headlines and
stereotypes that they referring to the
Past press sorry wanted to pin on me so
you thought I may as well do the crime
so to speak some of that is sort of
similar to what we've heard from uh
Prince Harry in previous publicity tours
the difference of course is that this is
the evidence for the prosecution and we
get into that quite quickly we'll take
you through talking about uh especially
these phone hacking allegations and
we've got a long way to get through
understanding all of this but here's
where I was laying out my associates
during the relevant period I was in
regular contact and often exchange
voicemail messages with the following
individuals he then goes on to list
those individuals starting with his
Royal harness the Prince of Wales my
brother he's there as is Princess Diana
King Charles III his father other and
then there's people like Chelsea Davey
as well Mark Dyer a former Royal Equity
equity and still a close a friend of
mine so that's starting to get into the
weeds of why he thought some of this
evidence might have been taken
unlawfully and we'll get a bit further
into this and you can see this is um
when he's talking about how he uses his
phone so we'll just go back to the page
before and he says he can't remember
exactly when he got his first mobile
phone but he thinks it's when he first
went to Eaton when he was still a minor
so around
um 13 years old and here he is talking
about unusual mobile activities so I
remember on multiple occasions hearing a
voicemail for the first time there
wasn't new in inverse eCommerce but I
don't remember thinking it was
particularly unusual I would simply put
it down perhaps a technical glitch as
mobile phones were still relatively new
back then or even just having too many
drinks the night before and having
forgotten that I'd listened to it but
here he says and we'll just take you in
here oh hello that with the benefit of
knowledge I've now gained of the details
of how phone hacking took place I
believe they're both mine and my
associates voicemail messages were
hacked by the defendant that is the
Mirror newspaper group and that it used
other unlawful means to obtain private
information about me including material
that has come from listening to live
calls I also made on my landline so not
just voicemails there but also landlines
the idea of eavesdropping we're going to
keep going through this through the
morning understand these arguments a bit
better but it seems pretty explosive so
far